It's easy to spot fake news.
It's kind of easy to spot when you see it,
'cause a lot of it is very click-baitish.
There'st he kind of fake news that's like
a blown up picture of Owen Wilson,
it's like 'you won't believe how much weight
this actor has lost.'
We quizzed people on Venice Beach to see if
they really could pick out fake news headlines
like this one: 'Breaking News: Hillary Clinton
Killed During FBI Raid.'
That's false!
Trump Tower opens in Pyongyang, the capitol
of North Korea.
Yeah that's fake news.
Everyone we spoke to spotted those bogus headlines
easily.
But what about this one, from the progressive
news site Salon.com?
Donald Trump threatens to deport NFL players
who defy him and that's just the beginning.
He probably would say something super crazy
and dumb like that.
A lot of stuff has been happening with the
NFL lately and Trump
so I mean, and he does, I feel like he does
have the power, it could be true, yeah.
That's like a fake news headline, like he
said something along the lines of, like,
that someone could like extrapolate that from
whatever his tweet said,
but I don't think that's technically true.
That's pretty much what happened.
Trump said that players who don't kneel for
the national anthem
'maybe shouldn't be in this country'
and Salon took the logical leap to infer that
the president wanted to deport
insufficiently respectful players
but what about misleading headlines that come
from mainstream sources, like CNN?
Trump asks Japan to build cars in the U.S.
it already does.
True.
Yeah I did hear about that, I read about it.
He may have heard about it on CNN, which later
corrected the headline
to reflect the fact Trump said he wanted Japan
to build more cars in America.
Given that, would you consider that headline
to be fake, misleading?
It's just a little bit misleading.
Yeah the way it's phrased makes it sound like
he's so dumb.
As the media environment continues to fracture,
it's natural for consumers to gravitate to
sources they trust and ignore ones they don't.
But even respectable news sources often deliver
factual information subtly blended with commentary.
Take this Politico headline which states the
fact that the Fed raised rates
paired with an editorial comment that such
a move signals the strength of Trump's economy.
this news/commentary hybrid led some of our
interviewees
to believe the headline came from a pro-Trump
source.
I feel like that would be more not a mainstream
media source though.
I feel like it'd be Fox News.
It's actually Politico.
Politico?
Yeah.
And then there's the confounding fact that
partisan sources
occasionally report factual information
such as this fairly straightforward headline
about the content of recently revealed text messages
sent by an FBI agent high up in the Clinton
email server and Trump/Russia investigations.
Justice Department IG Report Says Peter Strzok
Had 'Biased State Of Mind'
Do you think that that sounds like a legit
headline?
Uhm yeah that sounds legit, what website is
that on?
That's from Breitbart, do you consider them
legitimate?
No it's awful!
Yeah so definitely screwed up on that one.
So what's the news consumer to do in this
confusing environment?
One proposed solution is the regulation of
fake news.
Congress held a hearing on just this matter
on October of 2017
with senators threatening the social media
giants to step up or be regulated.
You have to be the ones to do something about
it, uhm or we will.
French politicians have begun debating legislation
that would give judges the ability to block
what they deem to be fake news
in the months leading up to an election.
I think that infringes a little bit,
I would be surprised if judges in France can
review every news story possible.
I mean that just sounds crazy.
But Americans have proven much more skeptical
with polls showing a strong majority disagreeing
with government regulation.
Do you think the government should step in
and regulate it?
Nah 'cause the government is corrupt and every
time they touch something
it just goes like, like completely wrong.
You can say that government can play a role
in it
but then that kind of breaks, you know, freedom
of speech.
Do you guys think that social media companies
like Facebook or Twitter
should do something to stem the spread of
fake news
or should they control it or regulate it in
some way?
I mean they should but the issue there is
bias.
Americans have been slightly more open to
the idea of tech companies policing fake news
which wouldn't violate the First Amendment.
In general do you trust companies like Facebook
to be transparent and have accountability?
I do, yeah I do.
But there's a generational divide on the question,
with younger Americans being more skeptical
of tech giants regulating speech.
Do you trust those companies to be transparent
and accountable?
Of course not, no, what are you talking about?  No!
And perhaps in that generational divide lies
an answer,
younger Americans don't know anything else,
a fractured media environment
is the reality into which they were born.
They don't really watch the news, they're
not on in the morning watching Fox, like they're not!
Yeah no one watches TV anymore, nobody watches
TV anymore.
I don't go on Facebook as much anymore, like
Facebook is now getting for like older people.
Much concern about fake news is ultimately
rooted in a fear of echo chambers or filter bubbles
that cut off consumers from diverse viewpoints.
But that's an overblown fear with recent studies
showing
that most Americans are in fact exposed to
a diversity of viewpoints.
The echo chamber panic may ironically be largely
the result of an echo chamber of political journalists
telling each other it's a big problem.
We're more opposed to censorship I think because
we're so used to the variety of opinions online.
Media literacy and critical thinking skills
are the most valuable weapons for combating fake news
and Generation Z just may be more equipped
to navigate the complicated media landscape
than are Baby Boomers, Gen Xers or even Millenials.
The Baby Boomers don't understand it, you
know, and the Millennial kind of understand it
but they haven't, they aren't used to it in
the same way.
We're more able to do our own fact checking
and more willing to
whereas like my mom clicks on something and
is like
'this is the only article about this topic,
wow, I can't believe I found this!'
Owen Wilson really got fat.
He really did, look at him!